[Music]
Rebel Wilson and baby Royce soaking up
some sunshine it's amazing the actress
shared this drone shot of the
mother-daughter Duo hitting the beach in
the Caribbean giving the world a rare
look at the four-month-old it's cool the
two are on vacay with Rebel's fiance
Ramona agruma sharing lots of snaps of
their tropical Adventures I mean I was
so excited
[Music]
okay I just want to spill something
Rubble shared the news of her little
one's arrival via surrogate back in
November you hold the baby and cut the
umbilical cord and literally from from
that moment you're just like it was just
like amazing and so emotional she's just
my little miracle little racy and she's
just so cute it's like only gotten
stronger like such a team and like I
think it's just made me and Ramona like
an instant family the couple began
dating last year and confirmed their
romance in June 2022 for me there was
something about turning 40 that I just
was like okay I feel like I'm stepping
into my own power the star revealed it
was her first same-sex kiss on screen in
her movie the almond and the seahorse
that opened her heart to finding love
with a woman I never kissed a woman
before and then it kind of led to this
kind of Discovery and which led to my
awesome partner Ramona and I I don't
know whether that would have happened if
I you know I might not have been open to
that if I hadn't have done the emotional
work work and then the movie that it was
kind of like a little crack opening to
that possibility that possibility turned
into a fairy tale when the couple got
engaged in February
it's like love is in the air and as they
head toward walking down that aisle
seems they're enjoying life as
first-time parents
[Music]